kelly a 28 ans est porteuse d'une imc
c'est à dire une infirmité motrice
cérébrale
à sa naissance elle a eu un manque
d'oxygène dans son cerveau elle est née
paralysé du côté droit se déplacer seul
de son fauteuil à son canapé cela fait
partie des facultés qu'elle a récemment
acquise car depuis qu'elle vit seule
dans son propre logement
elle a dû s'adapter se débrouiller et
ainsi gagner en autonomie à manger je
fais pas changé mais j'arrive à me
débrouiller pour faire à manger je
j'arrive à faire mais transfère par
exemple du canapés ou fauteuils tout
seul mais c'est vrai que j'arrive à
faire beaucoup plus de choses tout seul
maintenant que je suis le projet de
kelly et d'être indépendante avoir un
logement elle une étape cruciale pour
laquelle il a fallu un accompagnement
global tant au niveau médical que social
elle prend contact avec le service
d'accompagnement médico-social pour
adultes handicapés
le sam sein de la fondation père favron
le service a été créé pour favoriser le
maintien à domicile des personnes qui
sont porteuses de handicap
donc les trois grandes missions du
samsah c'est de privilégier maintien à
domicile donc bien sûr en tenant compte
des attentes des besoins de la personne
et de sa singularité veiller au
bien-être physique et psychique par la
coordination médicale et paramédicale et
là et favoriser l'intégration sociale
familiale aux environnements talent et
l'exercice de la citoyenne qu'il est
qu'ils n'avaient jamais habiter seul
auparavant
la fée l'accompagner dans les premiers
temps pour pour une mise en confiance
dans ce nouvel environnement
voilà donc voilà l'accompagnement
éducatif a été mis en place autour de ça
j'étais quasiment on va dire dans
quelques années sans être suivi par un
institut et à un moment donné j'ai vrai
qu'à un moment donné je me suis dit
est-ce que moi tout seul je vais pouvoir
réussir à aller au bout de mes de mes
objectifs de mes envies de mes rêves
et tout ça c'est entre guillemets pour
ça que ça me semble beaucoup aidé
ce projet d'indépendance
il a également fallu le faire accepter
par sa famille qui est très protectrice
au début c'était compliqué à faire
accepter tu dis ma famille la famille
souvent pour une personne handicapée sur
20 sacres on connaît à surprotéger et
tout ça mais ça maintenant ils
commencent à s'habituer au fait que
bunge et liquide sel et que j'ai des
projets professionnels social ou autre
chose
oui ça fait du bien aujourd'hui kelly
est quasiment indépendante elle
bénéficie du soutien de ses proches
mais elle est en capacité de se déplacer
de manière relativement autonome elle se
déplace dans les lieux publics à l'aide
de plus en plus confiance en elle dans
les déplacements dans les démarches se
positionne beaucoup mieux qu'avant
vis-à-vis de ce qu'elle veut vis-à-vis
de ses choix
c'est valorisant place que ce débat
aujourd'hui je fais ça l'aurait encore
un an
je ne pouvais pas le faire et de volonté
de courage pour arriver à ce niveau
d'autonomie
kelly a dû passer de nombreux obstacles
pour sans cesse dépasser ses limites
ça peut être contre a dit contrat
victoire pour certaines personnes moi
j'ai tire cette force dans toutes les
difficultés que j'ai rencontrées quand
j'étais plus jeune
quand j'ai envie d'abandonner je me dis
quand tu étais plus jeune tu assumes
nisaa ça et aujourd'hui regardes tu en
es tu es chez toi tu fais des choses tu
tu t'es quand tout le monde sait à
chaque fois qu'il m'a dit ça ça me
remonte le moral
kelly veut aller encore plus loin dans
la conquête de son autonomie elle
souhaite mettre à profit son bts de
management et trouver un travail
le samsah l'accompagner dans cette
démarche en trouvant un stage qu'elle
démarre en juin et a arrêté les études
en 2010 et depuis que j'ai arrêté je
n'ai pas travaillé et du cou j'avais
peur d'avoir perdu tout ce que tous les
acquis que j'avais acquis pendant ma
scolarité
du coup avec le sam st onge
je leur ai dit que je voulais un stage
pour me remettre dans le bain habitué au
rythme professionnel quand de trouver un
nom et là j'ai trouvé un stage au moins
de juin kelly sera suivie au maximum
pendant trois ans par le cnca les
professionnels mettent tout en oeuvre
pour assurer la plus grande autonomie
possible à la fin de cette prise en
charge
on va vers aussi un passage de relais
encore donne vraiment toutes ses
missions la ce pour sur le terrain pour
passer le relais auprès des différents
partenaires pour que la suite soit
assurée en tout cas si crédit souhaite
continuer satin aller au bout certains
demandent et puissent le faire même si
le samsah n'est plus là pour
l'accompagner d'un point de vue médical
pour kelly ça a été surtout la mise en
place d'un réseau médical et paramédical
en collaboration avec les libéraux
infirmiers et kinés il ya eu
deux en parallèle des demandes de
consultations avec des spécialistes donc
là on a accompagné kelly notamment pour
trouver des spécialistes qui était
accessible et qui avaient des cabinets
adapté malgré son handicap kelly a su
prendre sa vie en main grâce au soutien
de ses proches et un accompagnement
adapté
elle avance confiante sur sa propre
route
oui